for me working with better I beginning
cinema with Pedro and for me was always
so evident that play to play was having
fun I always had a lot of fun with him
and I was abandoned myself to the
preference creativity in this this joy
is true that I love him Pedro that even
he is passionate and he has very well
what what the things he he wanted to
coach from you and everything but he
always led this beautiful window open
about improvisation is much more than
that is intuition it's a powerful
intuition that something me like an
artist i like i like very much accident
in life in art too and this he is very
clever and coach the special thing that
can can arrive by accident I love that
and also about the characters that Pedro
has this oldest person of all this film
for us like a spectator like like fan
and I made a lot of time irrational
about his cinema is about the characters
they are strong they are survivors even
all the traumas even all the worst thing
they went through they know how aree
invited themselves they know how to
forgive the power of forgiveness the
most important power of forgive somebody
who has endured you but also to forgive
ourselves I love you Pedro we played
very sleeping carriers invaders films I
think we all feel very blessed to work
with you and we always hope we will work
with you again and again and I think one
of the most beautiful things as an actor
is something that also comes across as a
as an s spectator of your films but as
an actor you really feel that you you
live
drama to the deepest and if you said you
listened to tavola Vargas and Nina
Simone a and if you're happy you exude
happiness and if you see something that
moves you you cry and you are ecstatic
with it and as a as a viewer you have
that in your films and as an actor you
force us to live that which is something
that I think we're all very scared of
and very grateful that you make us do
that and that what you said is that it's
always compassion it's always with a
huge amount of compassion and you always
leave your characters and your public
you always leave them they always come
across they always make it through they
always forgiving they always forgive so
no matter how dragged around the floor
you've been you always come out a better
person tonight it's the night that we
are going gonna make it happen tonight
will God we put all the things aside
because I'm so excited and I yes can
hide it and I'm about to lose control
but I think I like it you know okay know
this song I'm so excited followed as
like a mantra during the shooting of the
last almodovar film into a big belly of
a plane and los amantes pasajeros okay
the los amantes pasajeros the spanish
title but the french title is this a
more by sergey won't you and the italian
title is alia and Gerry and but the
English title is and so excited
yeah you know and I'm extremely excited
because on behalf of the whole crew of
this amazing film I can say that the
film the trip was full of emotion
craziness passion love and above all
crazy turbulences and sexy turbulences